[Musica]
anche io vi porto a new york
siamo sul treno che va a nord verso
allen è il periodo prenatalizio quindi
le carrozze sono molto affollate e in
una fermata della metropolitana sale una
donna una madre nera con la sua
figlioletta
come vi dicevo la carrozza è molto
affollata quindi appena si libera un
posto la madre spinge la bambina in modo
che si possa sedere
la bambina si guarda attorno
da un lato c'è un uomo che legge un
giornale che l'altro c'è una donna una
donna che la osserva con uno sguardo
strano è una donna che ha una pelliccia
dei guanti di pelle un cappello a poroso
e nota una
espressione di disgusto nel volto della
donna le narici leggermente allargate
come se ci fosse puzza di qualcosa
il labbro piegato e quindi la bambina
comincia a chiedersi cosa ci sia di così
spaventoso da scaturire quella reazione
vede che la donna si sposta leggermente
tirasse il cappotto la bambina pensa che
forse ci sia uno scarafaggio che stia
camminando in mezzo a loro sedile quindi
anche lei si sposta un pochino e si
riavvolge nella sua tutina da neve
riguarda la signora è nota che lo
sguardo è rimasto questo pozzo questo
orrore è ancora lì e la bambina un certo
punto capisce che non c'è nessuno
scarafaggio perché lei lo scarafaggio
infatti la donna da lì a poco si alza e
cambia posso
questa storia è un episodio vero
accaduto a
oltre lord un attivista scrittrice
afroamericana che si definisce nera
lesbica madre guerriera e poetessa nei
suoi scritti oltre lord combatte e cerca
di sconfiggere razzismo sessismo
classismo e omofobia
perché vi ho raccontato questo episodio
perché secondo me molto potente nel
farci capire che tipo di reazioni
suscita la visione del corpo nero il
corpo nero al corpo nero storicamente
sono stati assegnati e tutta una serie
di significati che il filosofo e
psichiatra della martinica frantz fanon
definisce significati all'interno di uno
schema lo schema anche lui chiama
epidermico razziale in cui la pelle nera
l'epidermide diventa il più visibile dei
feticci il corpo nero ci dice fa non è
un corpo che porta su di sé storie miti
leggende e soprattutto una storicità che
deriva da 400 anni di schiavitù
ora io so che parlare di colore razza
crea sempre un po disagio perché
sappiamo che le razze al plurale non
esistono
non c'è un gene che ci identifica
appartenenti alla razza e quindi se
l'iraq se non esistono perché parlare di
colore
non sarebbe meglio per esempio quanti di
voi pensano che sia giusto guardare le
persone in quanto tali e non in base al
loro colore chi la pensa così
ecco anche se in realtà questo concetto
è bellissimo io trovo questa espressione
questa frase problematica perché chi può
dire io non vedo il colore vedo le
persone a un privilegio il privilegio di
sapere o forse neanche di rendersi conto
che nonostante si possano vivere molte
discriminazioni
per l'orientamento sessuale per
l'identità di genere per la condizione
socio economica il colore non sarà mai
tra quelli e quindi è per questo che
dobbiamo parlare di colore perché
solitamente c'è un colore che ha
attirato verso di sé dei privilegi
e del colore bianco è per questo che
questo privilegio in particolare viene
definito privilegio bianco forse
l'avrete sentito dall'inglese white
privilegi ora quando si parla di questo
privilegio a persone bianche come in
questo caso pensando avanza 9.9 per
cento delle persone in questa sala è
appunto una persona bianca c'è sempre un
senso di vergogna o anche di colpa ci si
sente in colpa
ecco io penso che infliggere un senso di
colpa o provare un senso di colpa non
sia per niente produttivo perché non
scegliamo noi il colore con cui nasciamo
però possiamo scegliere di educarci per
capire come mai abbiamo questo
privilegio come è stato costruito come
si manifesta e come possiamo usarlo
nelle lotte sociali e nelle lotte anti
razziste
il privilegio bianco però non è
semplicemente un astrazione è una realtà
come il razzismo
sappiamo che le razze non esistono ma il
razzismo è reale e penso che dei dati ci
possano aiutare i dati che vi farò
vedere vengono dagli stati uniti perché
negli stati uniti possiamo raccogliere
dati di tipo etnico
quando arriva il censimento le persone
possono identificarsi auto identificarsi
e tecnicamente
questo so che in europa suona
bruttissimo in realtà questi dati ci
servono perché con questi dati noi
capiamo chi subisce razzismo dove si
manifesta come possiamo combatterlo
e quindi ecco alcuni dati
come vedete questo è il reddito pro
capite quindi in blu abbiamo white
quindi la categoria bianca persone che
si definiscono
bianche in arancione persone che si
definiscono nere
vedete che il reddito pro capite delle
persone bianche e di 42mila dollari nel
2018 delle persone nere e 24.000
il tasso di povertà tra le persone
bianche sfiora l'otto per cento tra le
persone nere quasi il 21 per cento
si parla molto del sistema carcerario
statunitense e vediamo perché guardate
la popolazione nera fa il 12.3 per cento
totale eppure rappresenta il 33 per
cento della popolazione incarcerata
quindi un terzo della popolazione
pensiamo alle appunto al covi anche qui
la popolazione nera acquisti rifà 14
scatti la popolazione nera di 14 stati
degli stati uniti e del 18 per cento
eppure il 33 per cento delle persone
ricoverate sono nere
ecco questi dati
ci parlano ci dicono qualcosa però fanno
riferimento agli stati uniti e gli stati
uniti hanno una storia completamente
diversa dalla nostra quindi importante
conoscerla ma non dobbiamo certo imporla
nella nostra storia perché non avrebbe
senso e quindi parlerò della mia e di
esperienza e sono una persona una donna
nera italiana
e nonostante questo nonostante sia
italiana molto spesso mi viene fatta una
domanda
partito il 6
e quando dico roma c'è sempre un'altra
domanda
no vabbè ma di dove sei veramente perché
parli italiano così bene come fai ad
essere italiana quindi sembra che il mio
dire sono italiana crei un corto
circuito non alcune persone mi ha
cercato di capire perché
l'italianità se ci pensiamo si eredita
per sangue
se pensiamo alla cittadinanza italiana
non sia italiani perché si è nati e
cresciuti in italia se italiani perché
sia un sangue giusto un sangue italiano
quindi chi nasce in italia e non a
questo sangue è legalmente una persona
straniera quindi un bambino nato in
italia se non ha relazioni con appunto
una persona italiana o non ha questo
sangue trasmesso nelle generazioni fino
all'età di 18 anni dovrà vivere con un
permesso di soggiorno e avrò solo dodici
mesi il tempo per chiedere la
cittadinanza
l'applicazione è la domanda per fare la
cittadinanza è molto complessa molto
burocratica costosa i tempi di attesa
sono lunghissimi almeno quattro anni nel
frattempo la persona si trova a vivere
in un limbo non perché ci sono
tantissime limitazioni e pensate che
alcune persone preferiscono aspettare 28
anni per essere poi naturalizzate perché
sembra più semplice
però chi nasce per esempio in argentina
da un trisavolo che nel 1872 ha lasciato
l'italia per andare in argentina
ecco questa persona si riesce a
dimostrare la cittadinanza del proprio
trisavolo può comodamente fare domanda
on line e se tutto va bene dopo qualche
mese riceve un passaporto italiano
ecco quindi cominciamo a vedere come il
sangue e la bianchezza siano fattori che
ci toccano da vicino
ma un altro effetto di questo privilegio
bianco si rifà anche in quello che
studiamo se pensiamo e vediamo l'italia
come un paese bianco certo studieremo
una certa storia di matrice euro
centrica e verranno escluse molte storie
ecco io a scuola
a parte che sono sempre stata l'unica
persona nera nella stanza nella classe
nell'autobus un guardassi ero una
bambina negli anni ottanta crescevo
reggio emilia infanzia bellissima ma
certo ero sempre io a scuola appunto non
ho mai avuto un compagno una compagna
non bianca non parliamo poi del corpo
docente ma non mi sono mai vista
rappresentata in quello che io studiavo
eppure io esistevo la mia famiglia
esisteva perché queste storie io non
l'ho mai studiate perché non mi venivano
raccontate e anche per questo che ho
cominciato a fare questo lavoro di
ricerca forse a interessarmi del
colonialismo perché era un po l'anello
mancante del mio processo formativo
una persona che mi ha aiutato molto è
stato il sociologo mauro valeri mauro
valeri purtroppo è scomparso qualche
anno fa però prima di lasciarci ha fatto
un lavoro di ricerca impressionante nel
rintracciare queste storie è affatto una
ricerca minuziosa andando indietro nel
tempo
ecco ad esempio alessandro de medici
duca di firenze nel 1530 nato da
simonetta de collevecchio una donna
africana arrivata in schiavitù
san benedetto il moro diventa santo nel
1807 è un francescano diventa santo
quando nell ordine dei francescani neri
non sono ammesse a diventare preti lì
lui nasce in sicilia da due genitori
etiopi anch'essi schiavi
avete mai sentito parlare di domenico
mondelli
primo avviato re nero al mondo
nella prima guerra mondiale l'italia a 4
aviatori neri e lui è il primo a livello
mondiale prende il brevetto nel 1912
ma c'è una storia due storie che per me
sono davvero importanti sono le storie
di un fratello e di una sorella giorgio
e isabella marincola loro hanno una
storia particolare perché nascono nella
somalia fascista giorgio nasce nel 23
1923 isabella nel 1925 e dopo due anni
il padre non li lascia alla madre
biologica ma li porta in italia per
essere cresciuti giorgio verrà mandato
in calabria da uno zio che non aveva
figli e isabella rimane nel nucleo
familiare
vi consiglio un libro bellissimo ti mira
romanzo meticcio scritto dal figlio
d'isabella in cui ev ming 2 in cui
vengono raccontate le loro storie
isabella però una storia molto difficile
di violenze subite fin da piccola dalla
madre adottiva una donna sarda che si
ritrova una bambina nera in casa imposta
dal marito segno della sua relazione con
una donna africana quindi immaginiamoci
anche questa situazione
giorgio invece vivere un'infanzia molto
serena e poi ritornerà a roma per fare
il liceo e li incontrerà un professore
che gli cambierà la vita più albertelli
e giorgio muore a 22 anni nell'ultima
strage nazista è compiuta in italia
quello che è interessante che quando il
suo cadavere viene trovato
viene definito il cadavere inspiegabile
è un uomo nero con una divisa da
partigiano e non si riesce a capire chi
sia qualcuno ipotizza che sia un medico
sudafricano
qualcuno pensa che c'è un soldato afro
americano ma nessuno immagina che era un
ragazzo italiano era italo somalo ed era
morto per liberare l'italia appunto
ora perché io vi ho raccontato queste
storie perché se studiassimo le storie
che compongono la storia ci renderemo
conto che l'italia non è il paese che ci
viene raccontato per esempio sapremo che
la presenza di persone nere in italia
risale a tempi antichissimi e ci
renderemo conto che l'identità non è un
fattore biologico
dovuto a un colore di passaporto a
presunti valori ematici quanto sangue
italiano bisogna avere per essere
italiani
il bianco e i privilegi legati alla
bianchezza sono stati posti al centro di
sistemi classificatori che per secoli
hanno marginalizzato
escluso e segregato e allora sta a noi
trovare delle strategie alternative di
resistenza strategie che ci aiutino a
decolonizzare quello che studiamo e
quello che leggiamo strategie che ci
aiutino a cambiare il modo in cui
concepiamo la società che abitiamo che
costruiamo e quindi vorrei lasciarvi
con un messaggio che ci ha lasciato un
poeta molto famoso che conoscerete tutti
e questo poi c'è questo poeta ci dice
emancipiamo c dalla schiavitù mentale
perché solo noi stessi e noi stessi
possiamo liberare le nostre menti grazie
[Applauso]
di sosa grido